[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael
rosenbom Ryan taes is here hello thank
you uh you know we had Ryan we've had
some great podcasts lately we have we
had uh two good ones yesterday great on
yeah two great ones and the ones that
are airing are really good everywhere
from Tom Ellis to to our 300th episode
with Tom Welling and I want to thank
everybody again for that um it's been
great we had K Reeves we had uh and dog
star dog star we had we had a great year
yeah and uh we're kicking it off right
this year we got a lot of great guests
and uh I couldn't do this without you
you know there's so many podcasts out
there but we've been around a while and
uh you know we talk about mental health
and real stuff and I think that's why
people gravitate towards the show but uh
if you want to support the show more and
help us which we could use your help uh
go to patreon.com inside of you that's
patreon p a o n.com inside of you it's
like a streaming service imagine you
know people give you know they help out
they they subscribe to streaming service
services so yeah so you know if you want
to do that um and there's a lot of perks
on the patron if you go there's I'm
doing a YouTube live with folks the top
tiers I'm doing a zoom with top tiers
get their names called out on every show
um they get to ask questions to the
guests um they get boxes sent by me
every couple months and notes and it's a
really good time and it's become a real
good family on the patreon so
patreon.com inside you and uh we're
going to get into the episode in a
minute um also my new product Ros puppy
fresh breath you can go on Amazon and
get it it's uh an additive for your dogs
just to drop in their bowl and their
breath is better period it's uh odorless
tasteless it's awesome and uh my
picture's on the bottle oh yeah Rosy's
puppy fresh breath now does it work on
you you know what I'll try it I'll try
it if it's good for my dog it's good for
me well it's Goose good for the goose is
good for the what is it what's good for
the goose is good for the gander what
does that mean uh
it's I think it's akin to happy wife
happy life it's good for the goose it's
good for the Gamba yeah I guess so
Gander being a male goose yeah uh the
handles here for inside of you if you
want to follow us and subscribe which
would help and if you want to write a
review what are the handles Ryan inside
of you pod on Twitter inside of you
podcast on Instagram and Facebook uh by
the way the uh the inside of you online
store is available for we have there's
if you love Smallville there's tons of
great merch that you can't get anywhere
signed by me and also
um yeah so you might want to go to the
inside you online store and get some
stuff there's stuff that you just can't
get um I'll also be at some cons I'll be
in North Carolina on the 17th the
weekend with Tom Welling we're doing a
Smallville night you can go on my
Instagram at the Michel Rosen bomb and
you could certainly hit my link tree and
it tells you everything I'm doing uh I
apologize for canceling the live event
but scheduling and my surgery and all
those things and uh yeah [__] happens
would you say shake your link tree like
give it a shake like you know you're
getting a you can get my shake my link
tree yeah like it's like it's a tree
that almost sounds rough shake my link
tree no like you're getting an apple
yeah I know what you're saying there
buddy but let me tell you something
about myself I am Thrice
divorced uh Katie sack off has been on
the podcast before Mandalorian um long
Meer tons of work Battle Star Galactica
she's really great on this podcast and I
did her she has a new podcast we talk
about and and so much other stuff she's
so open she's so sweet I love having her
on and um yeah is there anything else I
should mention thanks for listening to
tville as well promote tville and um
yeah everything's going Ryan is
everything going good I know you're
going to do better help now yeah I'm I'm
oh jeez that was loud yes yes uh yeah
you're back on get back into I took the
holidays off yeah which is could be a
mistake uh yeah but you know I my
therapist retired and so I just decided
to take a little break take a little
breather and then I'm just G to get back
on it yeah well that's great it's it's
so easy man it's really I mean you could
tell people how easy it is it's super
easy I mean you fill out like a little
questionnaire and then you're off to the
races yeah pretty much just that easy
just that easy yeah we could all use
help believe me I go to therap I just
got out of therapy right before this
good we talked about all my um
ailments and uh life and you know
there's a lot of good positive things
you know that you start to figure out
you become aware of things work on
things I love it um all right without
further Ado let's get into it let's get
inside of Katie sackoff it's my point of
view you're lening to inside of you with
Michael Rosen
[Music]
B inside of you with Michael rosenbom
was not recorded in front of a live
studio audience yeah the mic's a little
I'm just going to play with it for a
second you do whatever you want I
usually I like to play with it until I
get in the right spot you're not making
noise over there K once I get it in the
right spot I feel in control now you're
in control now I'm in control I actually
got to see you in control just about 30
minutes ago I was on your new podcast
that's coming out called Blah Blah Blah
with Katie sackoff yes blah blah blah
why did you like there's there's so many
podcasts
and it's so I hate to use the word
what's another word for oversaturated
because everybody oversaturated
oversaturated oversaturated everybody
uses that word it's uh there's an
abundance of podcasts and what do you
what a why did you want to do a podcast
and um what's the subject matter I know
CU I was just interviewed and it felt
very it just felt you were very you made
me at ease you made me feel comfortable
we talked mental health we talked life
in ways it was sort of like mine
but like more of a a female perspective
yeah so maybe that's what what is it
what is it Katie well you basically just
hit the nail on the head I want to just
have real authentic conversations with
people about life and about work and
about love and mental health and aging
in this business everything you can
think of um and I want it to be from the
female perspective because I don't feel
like there are a lot of women doing
podcasts well but there I don't I didn't
feel like the way I wanted to do a
podcast or listen to a
podcast was there with a female so you
wanted to fulfill that void I did see a
little bit of a void in a weird
oversaturated place that I thought that
I could find a I could find I could
carve a spot out for myself yeah um and
that's what it's supposed to be it's
supposed to just be conversations with
two friends and we joked about this but
if you could be a fly on the wall while
two friends are having a cup of coffee
that's what it should feel like it
should feel like you're ease dropping on
a conversation yeah and and I appreciate
that you sort of you know you said that
doing this podcast kind of gave you that
you know a little bit of the idea to do
this and you asked me questions and like
you know we were in the car and what
like you know just ideas and you know my
ultimately I was just like just be
vulnerable be real you know authentic
genuine those words are the number one
part of the show you as long as you are
doing this because you care because you
care about the guest you want to listen
you want to get something from them and
your audience and you give them that
same appreciation I think that um over
time people will gravitate towards you
you know I uh text my buddy Ethan who's
a massive Star Wars fan and I am too but
he knows a lot more I I I don't go down
that whole Rabbit Hole of all these new
shows as much as I loved
Mandalorian that was the one to me that
felt like old school and it
just I mean it captivated an audience I
mean people were just holy
[__] when you know his text to me was
like he just loves the fact that you in
Clone Wars you also
voice B right I did yeah so for like um
isn't that a city in Florida baton it
actually is
Boon um uh and I was going to just make
it politically inappropriate joke but
never mind I voiced her for about 10
years um not many episodes though not
many episodes I only did probably Eight
Episodes but she made an impression you
know she was around sort of at the end
of Clone War she was in Rebels as well
like she had she had an integral part in
the um the the tone of what what it was
when it ended so it did make complete
sense for her to find her way into
Mandalorian so you were doing this voice
before you did the real part yeah at
live action not the real part live
action I mean how many times do somebody
the voice of something and they make
them the live action I I can't think of
any so are there I think that I might
have been the first actually and I I
don't say this with an ego I just say
that I it's been I've been told I've
been told that it's gone the other
direction but never this direction are
you uh so what right before the strike
were you filming no no oddly enough I we
finished we finished this last season
last like April like over a year ago um
and then uh the next season Amando
hasn't started yet what are you going to
tell me about that I am so good at not
giving away spoilers at this point cuz
I'm so scared that like someone from
Disney will swoop in and like you never
hear from again are things that
happen a answer me this we'll beat
around the bush yeah yeah are they going
to shock the audience um you know I
think that's the thing with this um
universe is that no matter what you do
you will always shock 50% of the
audience you know what I mean um and so
I I'm I'm sure it will I'm sure it will
I'm sure there will be fun crazy moments
that people water cooler about you know
what I mean um yeah for sure how many
episodes you can't even tell me that huh
no how many episodes did they
shoot you can't even say that I mean
they've done I think they've done like
eight every season okay so you're not
telling me anything that no there's
probably eight and so you're in either
one or one up to eight of them that I
mean that would that would be
one guess that would be one logical gu
that would be one guess I bet you're in
five episodes that's my guess I bet
you're in five episodes guess um are
they very like Hush Hush like literally
you can't say anything yeah and who
tells you this no one really they don't
say anything no it's like that I mean we
sign ndas that are like super thick um
and but you don't really you don't
really get a conversation from anyone
unless you make a mistake and then you
get a conversation I haven't really had
one yet so you haven't made mistakes no
I mean I've made a Shon of mistakes just
not in spoiler world is there anyone in
this upcoming season that you've already
shot where we had high altitude what are
you doing no I get like weird um
migraines I yeah I have TMJ so I grind
my teeth a lot I do too I grind my teeth
all the time you know that I grab my
teeth I always can hear it but you can't
hear it cuz it's in my mouth
Jason but I'm sure yeah you know yeah so
I my ears when I grind a lot it's sort
of like I need to itch my ears and I
blow I blow a lot do you love this world
do you honestly hope this world
continues for you the Star Wars world
for many many years to come yeah you
know it's been such a dream come true I
I I was a fan of of the original trilogy
when I was a kid um my dad introduced me
to them my dad is a huge Star Wars fan
um and and I I used to joke that you
know when I moved here I used to joke
that if if someone calls for me to be in
Star Wars I I'll beg them tell them I'll
be a rock I'll do whatever they want so
Clone Wars was just such an amazing
opportunity for me as like a fan of the
the the universe to be in this world um
and so it's just she is literally the
gift that keeps on giving I never
dreamed that I would be such an integral
part of season 3 and and I just just I I
want to keep playing her
until there's no story lines left to
tell in the Clone Wars she doesn't die
right no MM does she die ever anywhere
in any Universe no she hasn't she hasn't
as of that I know of she's not dead
there's no speculation or she still
alive and kicking would that just be
nightmarish if somebody goes It's the
End of the Road when that time comes
will you'll be really emotional when
they're like hey you know this is all we
can do with the character for right now
I think so I think so but at the same
time like I like 100% thoroughly respect
what Dave and and Dave fa filon and John
favro have created and what they know of
this character that if they said that I
would be like okay cool like that was
really awesome it was really awesome do
you have any uh conversations with them
as friends like during the year or is it
not really like you're like they're
great but you you could text them and
just say hey I'm think you blah blah
blah yeah you know the older I've gotten
the more I do that where if I'm thinking
of someone or if I have a a a fond
conversation with someone about someone
else I usually will let that person know
that they were on my mind and in my
thoughts that day because I you know we
talked about this a little bit before
there nothing's guaranteed you know like
I just want to tell people that they
matter that they matter and that you
know I enjoy them and I think of them
yeah I think that's important you text
them every once in a while just to say
hi who's nerdier favro or filon oh my
god filon well I don't know I would say
who tries to be cooler but
isn't me you um no they're both pretty
cool they're both pretty cool John's
pretty cool Dave is uh Dave is is quite
wonderful they're both just awesome yeah
yeah I met John before he's he was
really sweet yeah he's super wonderful
he's great boss
inside of you is brought to you by
rocket money rocket money listen to this
you're going to save money by using
rocket money this is an amazing amazing
app Ryan I use it um and the great thing
is we all have subscriptions and we
never remember that we still have
subscriptions we we get you know Floy
has a series on that we want to watch
right we watch the Floy we go okay we'll
give you $5.99 $109 9 whatever the price
is I'll watch it the program and I'll
delete it well 10 months later you
forgot and now you owe 150 bucks to Floy
for watching one little show that you
actually was crap yep so rocket money
does all this for you um do you feel
like money is just flying out of your
account and you have no idea where it's
going to well I know it's all the
subscriptions um streaming devices
fitness apps delivery services parenting
apps it's endless and I'm guilty of this
I I admit rocket money is a personal
finance app that findes and cancels your
unwanted subscriptions monitors your
spending and helps lower your bills yeah
I can see all my subscriptions in one
place and if I see something I don't
want I can cancel it with one tap I
never have to get on the phone with
customer service and you know how big
that is they'll even try to get you a
refund for the last couple of months of
wasted money and negotiate to lower your
bills for you by up to
20% all you have to do is take a picture
of your bill and Rocket money takes care
of the rest rocket money has over 5
million users and has helped save its
members an average of $720 a year with
over $500 million in canceled
subscriptions stop wasting money on
things you don't use cancel your
unwanted subscriptions by going to
Rocket
money.com inside that's rocket
money.com inside rocket
money.com inside do it save money now
inside of you is brought to you by
wondery even the Royals being a king or
queen might seem enticing but more often
than not it comes at the expense of
everything else like your freedom your
privacy and sometimes even your head the
creators of Wes even the rich are
bringing you a brand new podcast called
even the Royals where hosts Brooke and
Arisha pull back the curtain on royal
families past and present from all over
the world to show you the darker side of
what it means to be royalty from stories
about one of the most infamous Royals in
history Marie Antoinette but everything
you know about her is wrong after she
became Queen at just 19 years old she
ended up in a battle with the French
press and started a series of impossible
to believe events it's History's
Greatest smear campaign and it had
deadly consequences or what might be the
worst Royal marriage of all time between
King George ivth and Caroline of
Brunswick it's a story involving
catfishing fake pregnancies and It All
Leads to a divorce trial where the whole
world sat on the edge of their seats to
see how it would all play out follow
even the Royals on the wry app or
wherever you get your podcasts you can
binge even the Royals ad free right now
on wonder
plus I mean you know I I know that you
were once a swimmer and you got an
injury and that kind of took you out but
you really wanted to swim you you you
were you you had aspirations of sort of
like Olympics Olympic sort of [__] I
mean in my wildest dreams yes for sure
um I I absolutely could have SW in
college for I believe that and had like
a really great run in school um are you
still good when you go swimming you can
tell like well this girl's a
swimmer yes and no yes and no um I don't
really swim for fun anymore I think that
like um you know all those Daily Doubles
and Dryland training took it out of me
and now I'm like I just sort of like
when I get in a pool now I sort of like
abandon like wild abandoned play like a
child like like I do handstands and I do
like circles under the water I just
that's what I do they all make fun of me
when I go into a pool I always tell who
who whatever friends with me let's see
how who could do the most sumers salts
underwater yeah and they're like why do
you want to do this I'm like I don't
know it feels good it makes me tickle it
tickles me tickles my stomach I love to
drop my daughters too and like we I love
to drop all those stuff in the bottom of
the pool and like swim down with her and
and get them and does she have her eyes
wide open MH and we look at each other I
always love those videos of babies
underwater going eyes Nirvana ask yeah
yeah if you weren't going to become an
actress you know like
honestly what would you like to do like
what because you love it so much I mean
you're doing a podcast but like if you
weren't in the entertainment industry
what would you be doing right now like
right now I mean right now at at uh 2:30
PST so I think if you asked me when I
was you know 16 I would have said that I
would have gone into journalism or I
would have done something on camera or
something like that um
now God life is just about Leisure I
want you know I want to and and and not
that I can afford to have a life of
leisure but like I I want to spend time
with my family in relaxing settings
doing joyful things
um as much as possible sure um I would
love to to um make wine I would love to
have um my own Winery but I need to be
in a place financially where making
money is not um not important are you
saying that uh Disney doesn't pay a
lot they're notorious for not really are
they you know one of the things that
happened in our industry with streaming
is that um the consistency of work went
down because the holds remain the same
um and what that me for your audience
that means that the length of your
contract you basically are under
contract from a certain date to a
certain date and they have any time
within that date to pick you up for the
next season um they usually wait till
the last minute they prevent you from
doing other stuff and the problem is
those those holds are insanely long
they're like 12 13 16 months from your
last day on set not from the beginning
from your last day on set and the
problem is you're doing Eight Episodes
now you're not doing 22 anymore right so
you can't rely on a big paycheck right
no and it's it's your time on hold is so
much longer now and you know they can
say we're not preventing you from
getting work but other companies won't
touch you with a 10-ft pole if they know
you're under contract with someone else
so there's a there's a lot of downtime
one of the things is the residuals
actors used to be able to support
themselves off residuals during those
insane long holds that doesn't exist
anymore so so you know um they pay me
very well and and well enough for sure
um but I would love to have uh more
episodes or shorter hold times for sure
and not just with that company with any
company yeah I mean look these the roles
that we get you know in this industry we
don't know how long they're going to
last we don't know if they're going to
last a season or get cut short
not or whatever it is so all this time
that you work on you make what seems
like a significant amount of money yeah
some more significant than
others uh you know you don't know what's
next though and most of the time people
have jobs they work nine to five jobs or
whatever they're doing they know they
have work tomorrow next week as far as
they're they have their job for the most
part but actors it's a again a famine
yeah you're just well this Project's
over I got to go get another job so
you're always looking for another job
yeah and so it's uh you know yeah it's
it is like that and it's a little um
terrifying when you have a family as
well because our insurance is is
completely tied our health insurance is
completely tied to our the amount of
money we make and if you're on hold and
you start to go well crap you know
everyone's like you know and people and
it's not it's not them being rude it's
not anything but people just don't
understand the industry they're like why
don't you work for Marvel why don't you
go work for blah blah blah and I'm like
same thing I'm like guys they haven't
called me don't you think I would love
to have a job right now no one's called
my friends do the same thing but it's
usually about women why don't you date
Nicole Kidman man like well uh she's
dating a rockstar and I don't know her
well can't you meet
her I mean shut just shut up that's what
I want to say that's what I say to my
friends they think you know hey man we
want to know what you're it's yeah
because only because they don't get it
they don't know the world that we live
in that's kind of like it's not all that
glamorous a lot of times most times it's
not um it could be great but uh it's and
it's a small world too isn't it it feels
very small it's very small it's it is
very small and it's very like um uh you
know this is just really it's a really
tiny business everybody knows everybody
to a certain extent everybody has you
know known someone who's worked with
someone that that's worked with someone
and and you get to a certain point and
you're like well if the if the phone's
not ringing it's it's just because
there's nothing right for me right now
you know I know we didn't talk about
this last time I don't know if you even
talk about it since but you you're doing
a podcast already you're getting
personal you're getting vulnerable
You're Getting
open when did you have thyroid cancer oh
God 2008 2008 so rough 15 years ago yeah
and when you first got thyroid cancer
I'm guessing you didn't really know a
lot about thyroid cancer or your thyroid
I didn't know where it was on my body to
be honest I mean I did obviously cuz I
had a lump on it where is it it's right
in your neck so I have a scar there
right um I didn't know the scar yeah
they the surgeon did a great job but
like you know no I didn't think that I
would soon be an expert on thyroids and
now you are I mean within reisin yeah so
what was it that you went into was it a
random checkup were you fatigued were
you what was the symptom that you kind
of thought this is not right you know my
gynecologist actually felt the the
nodule during my exam uh can you imagine
she really really long arms no she she
was feeling my neck as they do and she
um she felt it and was like huh we
should go get that checked out and it it
sort of coincided with me being really
exhausted at the end of battl
star really like too much exhaustion
yeah I think so but I also think that
one of the things I've learned about
thyroid disorder is that it's very easy
to
blame um a lot of our discontent with
things in our life whether they be
physical emotional or or otherwise um on
your thyroid because it has so much
control over so much of your body it is
involved in so many different things
that it is possible that it's affecting
all of these things in your life or it's
also possible that you're slightly
depressed you're overworked you don't
sleep you eat like crap you're drinking
too much that's most the time what it is
90% of the time it's that and then every
once in a while it's a real reason can
you feel my thyroid real quick I can I
can why do you have a thing no I just
want to know yeah but does it feel
normal yeah there's no you're going a
little too long and I felt like you're
something was wrong no I've never felt
someone else's thyroid before was kind
of weird I've never felt somebody else's
thyroid before it might actually be a
little higher than that Michael oh so
you didn't know if you felt it yeah it's
like right here but you can't really
feel the thyroid I you could feel a
nodule on mine well that's what I'm
saying if I had a nodule or something
but I don't have I don't think no I
don't think so they know were you scared
instantly yeah yeah absolutely I mean
that anytime somebody tells you that you
have cancer no matter you know how old
you are or what the cancer is or or you
know the the survival rate or any of
those things I think that the seword is
such a terrifying thing and for me it
was like really really scary um but
afterwards I actually had a lot of
survivors guilt afterwards because my my
cancer felt so treatable um they removed
my thyroid they removed some lymph nodes
surrounding my thyroid and you know I
have to take a pill for the rest of my
life and work on my levels and things
like that yeah um but other than that I
was okay um I saw a lot of people at the
hospital that weren't um and there is a
lot of um a lot of guilt over that and I
was always sort of like ready for the
other shoe to drop so I've always been a
little terrified of doctors I go all the
time um but I you know I just had that
prua scan like I I just want to like
knowledge is power and so I'm like a
little bit of a hypochondriac when it
comes to medicine now because I'm a
little scared that that uh you know the
other shoe was going to
drop it's interesting I you know when a
doctor I'll be a gynecologist whatever
says I think you should get that checked
out I thought you said I'll be a
gynecologist like I thought you were
going to like I'll be it I'll be it yes
I heard I'll be I'll be in gynecologist
I'll be a gynecologist a gynecologist
all right so Al be it a gynecologist
yeah when she says that hm you know I
think you should get this looked at or
you me like well does it does it feel
bad were you constantly asking questions
and she's like I don't know it doesn't
look good or she just go go get it
checked out you know and and go to a
thyroid doctor and get it checked out I
I think that when you are young we are
blissfully like ignorant to to um
consequence and death you know and I
think that anytime that you encounter
something in your life that stops you
and and um sort of like opens your eyes
to the fragility of it all you become
hyper aware of it at a very young age
and that's what happened to me do you
remember when the doctor actually did
you go in the office when he said you
have thyroid weon cancer yeah was that
do you remember how you felt was it cuz
I imagine it's sort of numbing it is
numbing and then I felt really sorry for
myself um and then you know
um I used it I used it to feel sorry for
myself for a long time and about 2 years
after they removed my thyroid I had a
doctor literally say to me you need to
stop blaming the fact that you don't
have a thyroid on everything in your
life that's going wrong and take some
responsibility for this things that are
going wrong wow and I was
like wow okay okay yeah so I did I
started eating healthier I started
working out I got out of the
relationship that I was in I I made
changes in my life um and I took
responsibility for that that's amazing
yeah that's so cool what
uh what is it like without a thyroid do
you would would anyone even notice it
um no I don't think so I don't think
that anyone would notice with me um you
know my levels have always been really
great um I'm on top of it I'm constantly
getting my blood work done making sure
that that that my levels are okay what
levels cuz you have no thyroid thyroid
makes so THC THC THC if my thyroid makes
THC I am one lucky son of a [__] your
TSH so it's your your T3 and your T4
um but basically it I mean there's no
shortage of things that your thyroid
controls your metabolism your energy
your you know um your hormones your and
so without one I take a pill every day
and what does that pill do it is false
um it's fake T3 and
T4 really every day yeah so if the world
ended so during Co everyone was really
scared about not being able to to get
pills and shortages of things and stuff
like that um if I didn't take my thyroid
meds for 2 weeks it would be really
really really bad for my entire body it
would shut down you notice probably if
you don't take it for a day or two um so
so Synthroid has a shelf life of of a
like 14 days um so uh if you miss a day
it actually just lowers your overall
number of your microc cardiograms that
you're taking so if you're say you're on
150 and your doctor's like we really
want you to be on 145 well they don't
make a 145 so what they'll do is they'll
say one day a week take half a pill and
it lowers your whole level down things
like that so it's kind of like me with
Xanax or something just like a half if
you're going on a plane yeah but like
the sh life of Xanax is really short I
don't take Xanax anymore I haven't taken
one in years good it's bad for you I
mean just in the sense that it's very
addictive but I I'm on you know an
anti-depressant which helps with my
anxiety yeah um yeah it's amazing I went
through the like just everything and I
thought nothing's helping me yeah and
it's amazing each body is different each
brain chemistry is different so Lexapro
works for
me but it may you know I've heard
doesn't work for other people but it
works for a lot of people so there you
just have to do it and it's it is work
it took me a [__] year a year or more
to go through hell of all the different
drugs zof and I'm like oh God I just am
having more anxiety and then this other
I forgot the name of them all yeah but
they would just and I'm not saying they
didn't work they didn't work for me yeah
and then I I was about to give up I go I
don't know what to do my my psychiatrist
is like there's still some just hang on
yeah and I remember taking it and I just
waited waited and finally after a couple
months I got
go I'm definitely better do you do any
kind of anti-depressants or anything so
no not on any anti-depressant um but I
do like we talked about I I was
diagnosed with
ADHD um and so I situationally will take
half of a pill to focus my mind
situationally inside of you is brought
to you by Shopify listen to me I am not
really good with computers and when I
started having an inside of you online
store for people to shop at I thought it
was going to be a pain in the butt and
it's so freaking easy with Shopify
Shopify you can find everything like
your number one product that you sell oh
look it's right there everything is
right there for you your orders your
products add a product discount it's
right there it's so easy to use and um I
really love it Shopify is the the global
Commerce platform that helps you sell at
every stage of your business from the
launch your online shop stage to the
first re life store stage all the way to
the did we just hit a million orders
stage Shopify is there to help you grow
whether you're selling scented soap or
offering outdoor outfits Shopify helps
you sell everywhere from their
all-in-one e-commerce platform to their
in-person poos system wherever and
whatever you're selling shopify's got
you covered Shopify helps you turn turn
browsers into buyers with the internet's
best converting checkout up to 36%
better compared to other leading
Commerce platforms guys this is so easy
if you want to sell products Shopify is
the only place I can think of it's the
only place that I trust uh it's super
easy both my tville and inside you
stores people love them it's easy to
navigate um I urge you if you have
anything to sell to use Shopify Shopify
Powers 10% of all e-commerce in the US
and Shopify the global force behind Al
Birds Ries and Brooklyn and millions of
other entrepreneurs of every size across
175 countries sign up for a $1 per month
trial period at shopify.com
inside all lowercase shopify.com
inside now to grow your business no
matter what stage you're in shopify.com
SL
inside situationally is a tough thing
yeah because it's all the time so I feel
like if I just say I want to
focus
today then I'm not focusing the next day
and it also it's weird weirdly gives me
an energy yeah a little bit of a you
know like I'm focused I'm a little more
hyperfocused at least for the first five
hours of the day and then I kind of
Crash yeah yeah um but for me I take it
every day I don't take what you take and
I don't take ader all yeah but I take
something that works for me again called
viance and viance is um you can do that
you can take it when when needed but you
know
um you know these things give me normaly
something that I don't
really ass I haven't associated with my
whole life it was always like I didn't
realize I had this this anxiety my whole
life have you dealt with a lot of
anxiety or is it something that you
haven't really had the no I I did I mean
yes um and and situational anxiety I
think I I say that a lot because I don't
I for me personally I don't like to
label myself overall as something
because I feel like for me it would make
me lean into that a little bit more um
for me personally so um there are things
that give me tremendous anxiety in life
I am not an anxious person though in
general just there are things like I am
an horrific flyer I do not like fly I
fing not a fan of it not a fan um I um
you know um before I go on stage
terrifying terrifying to me my stomach
goes in knots I get really bad seriously
mhm like you're really you got to feel
like you go to the bathroom all that
stuff happens to you all of that stuff
happens all that stuff happens to me
except now that I'm on something that
levels me and takes away that intense
anxiety yeah it is bearable interesting
for the first time in my life I get that
and that's only been a year probably of
feeling like that oh well that's so
wonderful you found something whole
[__] life like anxious about
everything and I'm still anxious about
things don't get me wrong it doesn't fix
the problem you got to work on those
things but yeah but you're not a
genuinely an anxious person situational
like you said yeah but yeah yeah you
know I
I I found that a lot of my anxiety
stemmed from my insecurities about
things and I found that if I allowed
people into my life that validated my
insecurities my anxiety got worse so as
soon as I started removing people in my
life that that validated my insecurities
my anxiety got lesser validated your
insecurities yeah made you
think you were something you really
Warren but almost yeah almost like yeah
could accentuating those adverse things
yeah that these uh what do they call
them your uh traits your traits your
traits um yes and that is similarly
similarly can you say similarly say it
similarly good similarly similarly
similarly now it gets harder the more
you do it say toy boo five times fast
toy booat toy boo toy boo toy boo toy
boo pretty good toy boat toy boat toy
boat toy boat toy boat toy boat toy Bo
oh my gosh so do you like Fantastic Mr
Fox have you read this for a long time
but I haven't I don't know so my
daughter likes Dr Seuss and we have
Fantastic Mr Fox which I wish that I had
this book like when I first started
acting back in the day because the
tongue twisters in this book are just
insane I don't I can't like the Mr Fox
and the KNX on the socks has a box with
the thing and the it's just I mean like
they're crazy absolutely crazy you know
this one the big black bug bit the big
black bear and the big black bear bled
blue black blood no because I didn't
study so I don't know all these things
that people would do they'd all have
these like you know these tongue
twisters that they would do and I would
just like you know walk on set and be
like I guess I'll try today you know my
father is a fig plucker he plucks figs
he's the fastest fig plucker that ever
plucked a fig my sister is a sheet
slitter she slit sheets she's the
fastest slid [__] out slit a sheet wait
that's the one where you can say [__]
sheets or shets and yeah there there was
all sorts of ones like that um talking
about your traits though and people sort
of it's the same thing as having a
friend
that
just I don't want to say isn't grateful
but doesn't
appreciate things not just things that
you might do for them or things that you
might experience together but just sort
of has this attitude like and maybe look
it's depression it's whatever
self-loathing it's we all I I've dealt
with this but the sooner you weed out
people that bring you down yeah that are
not influencing a
positive aspect in your
life the faster your life will improve
it's just it's it's very easy yeah if
you're around someone and they're just
always they have issues and it's always
about them and there's problems and uh
it's just like me oh I I have a friend
who's always like oh of course that
happens to me of course of course
happens to me yeah bad news so there's
one thing where but if you feel like
you're always helping them you're always
trying to get them up you're trying to
lift their spiritually you can't be
everyone's cheerleader no that is going
to drain you for everything and it's
taken me so many years I would try to
make look I'm look I got to help my
unhappy self before I help someone else
that's unhappy yeah you got to put on
your mask before you can put on someone
else there you go that's what you do so
it's it's difficult but it's funny when
you do cut someone off and it hasn't
happened many times in my life my life
improves
exponentially yeah exponentially
absolutely absolutely you know I I and I
I mean this when I say this that I
didn't truly start living until my
husband loved me wow and he was the
first person I ever dated I I've dated
some wonderful men and some [__] mhm
but he was the first person who didn't
try to change anything about me and just
loved me wow and I there was such a
freedom and confidence that came out of
that um because he loved me and really
really really well and um allowed me to
just be myself and I finally for the
first time at 38 when I met him started
having fun again cuz I wasn't
embarrassed to be anything I was just
myself and started having fun and didn't
care what people thought of me because
this man loves me wow and it was really
beautiful and there was a lot of
strengthen that that I got from him just
by loving me do you think you you
learned to love yourself when he started
loving you because you thought you were
yeah wow yeah because I my husband
is probably the best man I've ever met
my dad's phenomenal I'm not talking
about my family my husband is such a
good kind man and I recognized from the
moment I met him that he was going to
make some woman very happy one
day and so the moment that he chose
me I literally in my mind
went oh my God I must not be that bad
like I must actually be a really good
person s that's beautiful and sad at the
same time yeah and yeah yeah you felt
worthy I did it made you feel like you
it made you feel not that worthy like it
just made you feel good
enough and for and stop just good enough
good enough good enough yeah good enough
more than I had never felt good enough
and because I'd never felt good enough
for other people I didn't feel good
enough for myself I felt my entire life
like I needed to be better I needed to
be somebody else I needed to be anything
but me because me wasn't enough and when
I found someone who I loved and who I
saw them as this amazing person and that
person loved me it immediately made me
realize I didn't have to be anything
other than myself and it was the most
freeing thing that's ever happened to me
and I truly started to like become
myself that is the key to meet some
someone whose agenda is not to change
you yeah you know but it could be anyone
right it doesn't necessarily have to be
a romantic partner I think that that it
could be anyone that you encounter in
your life that you respect as a human
being if that person says you're enough
just believe them you know yeah it's
hard when your whole
life you don't believe that you're
enough because because history has shown
that you weren't because you didn't feel
it because you didn't get it from the
people who were supposed to give it to
you yeah and then you get to a certain
point in in life where you say okay I've
got to work this out because this is
this can't be true this can't be true
that I'm not worthy that I'm not worth
it that I'm not um all these things
lovable or that I'm smart I'm not smart
I'm not and sometimes you have to put
logic you have to
say um are you
successful
yes do people appreciate your work yes
do you a you ask all these questions
that are presented that are pretty much
easy like do you love
yourself and that's always been a tough
one for me that's always been the big
kick in the ass it's like um I don't
really love myself but I like moment of
it like sometimes I go that was cool
dude and you did that altruistically you
didn't do that because the camera was
rolling you didn't do that because you
did it because you genely have a good
heart and those are the moments when I
say I like you I like that person I like
that element of you I like that moment
of you yeah so I haven't gotten to that
point where I'm like [__] yeah man I
love myself I don't I don't I don't look
at it that way yeah um I look at it as
like hey keep going after those moments
keep showing yourself that you are a
good person that you and you are but
like just keep doing good things keep
collecting moments yeah yeah do you find
yourself doing
that yeah yeah I I find myself
especially the older I get collecting
moments and collecting memories and
holding on to to little things because
I'm I'm I am very aware that
uh statistically I'm halfway through
Jesus why'd you bring that
up I feel like there's strength in that
though you're how old are you 43
somebody said like they were 51 which
got my attention I was on Instagram
everybody's a [__] spokesman now
everybody's got the [__] all
everything's worked out here's what you
need to do three things in life that if
you're doing you'll and it's all one do
this every morning breathe in five
breaths
and then number two look in the mirror
and brush your teeth with your left hand
instead of your right I'm like shut the
[__] up yeah you know everybody has
these ideas about what we should be
doing which is overwhelming yeah and it
should be like hey forget
everything put in your
body healthy things y that are going to
give you Natural Energy and don't eat as
much junk food yeah everything in
moderation doesn't mean you can't do you
could get hit by a truck tomorrow so I
don't want to get hit by a truck knowing
um God I wasn't eating that ice cream
sandwich it's just everything in modern
moderation yeah and you know being a
good person eating right A little
exercise a little you know being with
your friends uh letting go um that's
that's more that's better advice than a
lot of this [__] it just overwhelms me
it is overwhelming and I think what it
is get an ice bath get an ice bath I
have an ice bath I'm going to get one is
it is it magic
it is Magic we have a renew ice bath
which I absolutely love um they must
have given you that phras since you said
it no we I have my renew um we sold one
with our house when we moved from Los
Angeles we sold it with our house and
just bought another one and I I say this
because I I absolutely love it there are
other cold plunges out there like not
sponsored that that I feel like they're
less
expensive um they they have the little
thing that cools they have a lot of like
influencers that use them and they have
a cooler that makes it water cold uhuh
but then you have something like uh
renew that's like more expensive but
like it just works it's a it's an
investment and that's the way that I
looked at it it's an investment in my
health and and because it makes my hips
feel better because I have bad hips
really so I get in the cold plunge um so
it really reduces inflammation I believe
that it does absolutely I also believe
that you should probably talk to your
doctor first and make sure that your
heart is healthy I I know that a lot of
people I know that a lot of people are
like you know you take your cold plunge
and people like oh my God you could have
a heart attack yeah well I I also know
that I don't have a heart problem yeah
and I'm really
healthy
zic you know if you have heart problems
or you have di this will cause explosive
diarrhea in most people no I have no
idea it does I don't know maybe no I I
think that everyone is an expert and you
learn this when you are a parent people
are dying to tell you how to raise your
kid dying to because if if if it works
for them it's not enough they need it to
work for you as well because then it
validates what they did to their kid and
so like everyone wants to tell you do
this do that do this I do it too I'm
like have you heard of taking care of
babies go sleep train your kid and
everyone's like I can sleep chain my kid
that's so bad like so everyone has their
[__] and everyone tells you what they
did it works and whatever because every
what works for everyone is different
that's exactly everyone has their own
[__] but everyone wants to tell you what
worked for them because they're so proud
of it and it validates the fact that it
worked for them what I will say that
like this podcast with each guest that's
sort of like what works for you and when
the audience is
listening like hey Katie's advice might
just work for you my advice might work
for you every guest you might get a
little something a little nugget that
you go you know what that actually
worked for me yeah you know somebody
came up he's a patron and they support
the podcast and they're amazing uh
patreon.com inside and he came up to me
goes you know that athletic greens
really works and I
go awesome great and he goes yeah I go
how do you feel he goes I'll tell you
all when I don't take it I could feel it
I was like all right glad it works for
you cuz I really like it and Tom really
likes it we talk about it but again you
know it's you got to try things and and
and and see what works for you I like
athletic greens too they don't sponsor
my podcast maybe they will after this
maybe they will maybe I'll send them
this clip because I actually take
athletic greens da we're going to send
this clip to athletic greens see what
they say athletic
greens um and you go on my link treay
for all that stuff would you do Battle
Star Galactic
again it depends on the
script they came at and go we're doing
another eight
episode Special
Event yeah it would depend on who was
involved in the script for sure and who
was in charge but but you wouldn't say
yes without seeing
no all right did you have fun you in the
last one I did I did I I love that cast
We Are Family We Are Family for sure
Edward James almost everyone involved
everyone yeah everyone there's not one
person that was on that show and look
we're like family we've had some [__]
we've had some moments really every yeah
like we've had some onset no no but like
uh off out out of work it's been 20
years you know what I mean or 25 years
since we started whatever it was right
it's been a long time there's a lot of
different personalities like you can rub
people the wrong way you can Trisha hord
and I got in fight it's one of my best
friends got in a fight knock like knock
down drag out obviously we weren't
hitting each other but we had it we went
at each other screaming at each other
yeah in person yeah yeah not FaceTime
not screaming but like yeah really
heated why are you acting like a [__]
really heated really really heated and
we you know made it through it was it
about anything really that important if
you look back at it nothing's important
no no of course not it's important you
figured it out that's what's important
of course not it was obviously not
important and our friendship meant more
but you know what mean like so we we're
like family if we have some [__] but you
know you give them a kidney I like that
that's honesty yeah you know you have
moments with people and they become
family like even with me and Welling
like I feel like you know Tom I can say
anything to now we're close enough where
I could say hey dude don't do that like
go what are you [__] talking about
I'm like I'm I'm just telling you don't
do that or whatever and he'll say
something to me like hey when you talk
about that comes off as this I'm like oh
really so we listen to each other yeah
someone like dude shut the [__] up well
I think when when when you know that
someone loves you and wants what's best
for you and and you in turn love them I
believe that you can say most anything
to them because it's coming from a place
of of authenticity and and just you know
I would never intentionally hurt
somebody's feelings by saying anything
yeah you know what I mean yep um I know
you don't watch a lot of movies I don't
you're busy being a parent is exhausting
oh yeah it's exhausting no um and I I do
not know how I do not know how people do
it without help I don't know I don't
know either especially single moms
Here's To All The Single Moms God single
all the single dads single dads but like
here's to all like the like the single
parents who are making it work and
working their BS off and all they wish
is they had more time with their kids
yeah you know what I mean amen yeah
you're you're a good mom I could tell
you really care you're uh family first
you found the love of your life and you
have a kid together it's it's yeah you
know for sure I do feel that but I also
waited a really long time I waited to to
really meet the right person so you're
saying there's hope for me I'm waiting a
really long time there's hope for
everyone I think you know but everyone
has a different Journey right mine is
very different and and that doesn't mean
that it's easy you know it doesn't mean
that that my life doesn't have tragedy
in it yes I just choose not to focus on
it have you are your parents with you
they are they are yeah yeah yeah that's
good yeah both my parents are doing
really well my mom had a fall like four
years ago stupid [__] she was
like you say stupid [__] of course I
did and she would admit it my mom had
like live plants on the top top of her C
like cupboards ladies men if you're of a
certain age take the [__] plants off
the shelf and put fake ones up there for
God's sake my mom fell off the
counter by herself at home because she
was using the
stool the the bar stool as a as a ladder
to water the plants she fell she missed
the counter by like she could have died
she landed on her elbow shattered her
elbow oh my God broke a r i mean like
awful stupid [__] Jesus don't just
don't that was really hard my Falls a
lot she
falls well it's like the number one it's
like can't get up but it is it is it is
the thing that I know that's what scares
me my grandma's 95 and the only thing
I'm scared about falling falling one
fall see you yeah yeah I watch I I mean
I'm 43 years old and in very good shape
and I watch my
footing because like a fall could change
my life you know like I could I fall
down the stairs I a going to bounce
back did I do that on this podcast where
I talk about the comedian I thought was
so funny the black comedian he goes they
say 30 the new 30 new 20 they say 40 the
new 30 but when you 50 you're just damn
50 ain't nothing new about that [__]
only difference is you got to grab that
hand and when you're going up the stairs
you got to watch one foot in front of
the I yes it's true uh this has been a
real treat uh thank you for taking this
journey with me again absolutely and
look forward to thank you for letting me
invite myself on yes oh not really
that's a that's a little Inside Story I
thought she goes I wanted to be on your
podcast but she was asking me to be on
hers and then we worked it out to be on
both but yes we worked it out yeah we
did blah blah blah with Katie sack off
check it out Spotify Apple YouTube we go
into stuff with guests and real life
stuff it's not like gossip actory stuff
it's the same sort sort of idea but a
female perspective and I think you're
really going to enjoy it it's like she's
so open and cool if you've ever met her
at a con or whatever so you're
enormously talented I love you being
here we got to get you to the airport
right now thank you I appreciate you all
right bye
bye I I don't know what else to say
other than I love this
woman I wish I was there for this one
yeah you were uh I think you were sick
or traveling I think it was just
traveling traveling yeah yeah she's uh
she's fantastic so listen to her podcast
I'm a GU one of podcast check that out
um yeah uh that's about it really for
this episode if you like the show review
it send a review uh join patreon
patreon.com inside help the show out
it's it's all the people that are part
of Patron that really make this show
work um without you guys could afford to
pay good people like Ryan and Bryce and
and Jason and who's amazing team I I
wish that this podcast made so much
money that you just felt like you wanted
to always be at my house just hang out I
mean I could
just I could live here and you wouldn't
even know
it it sounds like a challenge why why
would I notice I don't know I sneak
around the Shadows there's plenty of
guest rooms you have your own Wing yeah
plenty of guest rooms there's one but
you know well no there's there's there's
really the office has a pull out bed
there you go the basement you could
sleep in you could sleep in here on this
couch would this couch be comfortable
this
one it's firm
it's fine thanks for uh indulging folks
it's quite boring what we're getting
into now uh I'm going to go right now
and uh talk about the uh top tier
patrons and give a shout out to all of
them who makes who make this show
possible um and a big shout out to
Westwood one who um produces the podcast
I mean Bryce really produces the podcast
but Westwood one gets our advertisers
which are you know which we'll we'll
mention and hopefully you don't fast
forward them and I really believe in a
lot of these guys so we don't pick um
sponsors that we don't like that's for
sure you know better helps one of my
favorites of all
time uh all right here we go top tiers
top tier patrons uh do you have the the
script here here do you have it right
there yeah I have this for you so you
could help me read I think people like
hearing you I think um it's very nice of
them yeah I think people really like you
Ryan you want to take my job over could
you do it uh no maybe I'll I'll work on
a on a spin-off series if this gets
popular well you're kind of like my Ed
McMahon yes
sir yeah you'll be my Ed McMahon Nancy D
Leah and Kristen little Lisa Yukiko Jill
e Brian h niik p Robert B Jason W Sophie
M Raj C Jennifer
N Stacy L Jamal F Janelle B Mike E Lon
Supremo 99 more Santiago M lean P Matty
s Linda
in um let's see Dave Dave hle Dave H
hello Dave I'm miss you I haven't talked
to you in a while um I hope to see you
soon we're going to do a a zoom with the
top tier patrons Dave Sheila G Brad d
Ray H Tabitha T
um let's do one like maybe New York or
Tom men Talia M Betsy D ran and C Corey
K Dev Nexon Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy D
Eugene and Leah Corey Mel s Christine s
Eric H Shane R Andrew M Oracle Amanda R
Kevin e you to do the New York I gonna
trip and fall hey what what's a good
phrase to get into it um like you say
New York New York yeah New York jel jel
jel jam and J lean J he Luna a Luna a
Mike F Stone H Brian L Jules mck Kendall
L Jessica B Kyle f citn j Brian a Maran
Louise
L Romeo the band the band you're getting
a little Chicago that easier for meent n
n Nikki L and the bast pacy and have it
yeah Randy s Nikki L April RM Randy s
jdw or P Rachel D Laurel LEL Melissa H
Nick W Stephanie and Evan Char Charlene
a Don G Jenny B John Jennifer ra Tina e
NG Tracy juny and Tas s those are the
wonderful top tier patrons but all my
patrons are wonderful every one of you
and um uh this has been a treat I hope
you enjoyed the episode and you continue
to watch and uh we're working hard to
get you great guests and there's a lot
of great guest coming up um you know who
we got coming up one of my
heroes Billy D Williams Lando Cal Reen I
can't believe italan calan Lando calan
Lando yep hi you
old I love it I'm excited my friend
Chris McDonald uh said you want Billy D
I think I can get Billy D for you I'm
like yeah can you come to the house sure
I love when they come to the house
that's always nice it's like a personal
thing it's like you know when keano came
here we're like talking piano it's it's
you know it's real um thank you for
listening to the podcast uh from the
Hollywood Hills in Hollywood California
I am Michael Rosen bomb I'm Ryan T I'm
here too yeah a little wait to the
camera we love you guys and please
always be good to yourself all right
most things are
nothings I'll leave it at that okay
[Music]
damn